[Music]
if you were to take any everyday object
say a coffee cup and break it in half
then in half again and keep carrying on
where would you end up could you keep on
going forever or would you find a set of
indivisible building blocks out of which
everything is made physicists have found
the latter that matter is made of
fundamental particles the smallest
things in the universe particles
interact with each other according to a
theory called the standard model the
standard model is a remarkably elegant
encapsulation of the strange quantum
world of indivisible infinitely small
particles it also covers the forces that
govern how particles move interact and
bind together to give shape to the world
around us so how does it work
zooming in on the fragments of the cup
we see molecules made of atoms bound up
together a molecule is the smallest unit
of any chemical compound an atom is the
smallest unit of any element in the
periodic table but the atom is not the
smallest unit of matter experiments
found that each atom has a tiny dense
nucleus surrounded by a cloud of even
tinier electrons the electron is as far
as we know one of the fundamental
indivisible building blocks of the
universe it was the first standard model
particle ever discovered electrons are
bound to an atom's nucleus by
electromagnetism they attract each other
by exchanging particles called photons
which are quanta of light that carry the
electromagnetic force one of the
fundamental forces of the standard model
the nucleus has more secrets to reveal
as it contains protons and neutrons
though once thought to be fundamental
particles on their own
in 1968 physicists found that protons
and neutrons are actually made of quartz
which are indivisible a proton contains
two up quarks and one down quark a
neutron contains two down quarks and one
up the nucleus is held together by the
strong force another fundamental force
of the standard model just as photons
carry the electromagnetic force
particles called gluons carry the strong
force electrons together with up and
down quarks seem to be all we need to
build atoms and therefore describe
normal matter however high energy
experiments reveal that there are
actually six quarks down and up strange
and charm and bottom and top and they
come in a wide range of masses the same
was found for electrons which have
heavier siblings called the muon and the
Tau why are there three and only three
different versions of each of these
particles this remains a mystery these
heavy particles are only produced for
very brief moments in high-energy
collisions and are not seen in everyday
life this is because they decay very
quickly into the lighter particles such
decays involve the exchange of force
carrying particles called the W and Z
which unlike the photon have mass they
carry the weak force the final force of
the standard model this same force
allows protons and neutrons to transform
into each other a vital part of the
fusion interactions that drive the Sun
to observe the W and Z directly we
needed the high-energy collisions
provided by particle accelerators
there's another kind of standard model
particle called neutrinos these only
interact with other particles through
the weak force trillions of neutrinos
many generated by the Sun fly through us
every second measurements of weak
interactions found that there are
different kinds of neutrinos associated
with the electron muon and tau all these
particles also have antimatter versions
which have the opposite charge but are
otherwise identical matter and
antimatter particles are produced in
pairs in high-energy collisions and they
annihilate each other when they meet the
final particle of the standard model is
the Higgs boson a quantum ripple in the
background energy field of the universe
interacting with this field is how all
the fundamental matter particles acquire
mass according to the standard model the
Atlas experiment on the Large Hadron
Collider is studying the standard model
in depth by taking precise measurements
of the particles and forces that make up
the universe Atlas physicists can look
for answers to mysteries not explained
by the standard model for example how
does gravity fit in what is the real
relationship between force carriers and
matter particles how can we describe
dark matter which makes up most of the
mass in the universe but remains
unaccounted for while the standard model
provides a beautiful explanation for the
world around us there is still a
universes worth of mysteries left to
explore ready to start exploring dive
right back into the perplexities of the
universe with these two lessons
[Music]